ich mache heute ein kleines
Gedankenexperiment mit ihnen und mit
euch also ich hoffe es ist okay wenn ich
euch sage weil ich studiere ich dutze
auch meine Studierenden und alle sonst
mit denen ich immer zu tun habe ich
hoffe das ist nicht so schlimm wenn ich
das einfach beibehalte weil sonst mache
ich es einfach automatisch falsch
zwischendrin also dann bin ich einfach
mal das wo du an alle anbieten und
hoffen dass es vor allem in Ordnung ist
an diesen Gedankenexperiment geht es
eigentlich darum dass ich ja
ursprünglich aus der
Literaturwissenschaft komme und mir die
Frage gestellt habe inwiefern eigentlich
Literatur und Lehre miteinander in
Verbindung gebracht werden können und
gerade in unserem spezifischen Fall zum
Thema Grenzüberschreitung also was kann
die Literatur oder Geschichten uns
liefern was ihr vielleicht in der Lehre
nutzen können und dieses
Gedankenexperiment ist eigentlich eine
ganze Hand voll Fragen die ich mir
stelle stellen kann in Bezug auf meine
Lehre
verliere online-lehre oder auch eben die
fachspezifische Lehre und da würde ich
euch einfach bitten dass ihr vielleicht
für euch selber mitdenkt was wäre was
wie könnt ihr das für euch umsetzen am
Ende habe ich auch ein kleines fandout
vorbereitet also wer bis zum Ende bleibt
kriegt noch das Handout hoffentlich im
Chat und wenn nicht per Mail einfach so
als Überlegung was kann ich denn tun um
meine Lehre dahin gehen so ein bisschen
zu reflektieren auf eine andere Art und
Weise vielleicht
und in der englischen
Literaturwissenschaft gibt es so eine
recht schöne Theorie nach juril Lothmann
der ist ein strukturalist eigentlich
also schon ein bisschen aus der Mode
gekommen so zeitlich vielleicht auch von
den
Strukturen an sich her aber ich mag
diesen Text ganz gerne der beschäftigt
sich eben mit der Struktur von
literarischen Texten also wie sind
literarische Texte aufgebaut und er hat
ein Kapitel zum Thema raumsemantik also
wie Räume mit Bedeutung aufgeladen
werden und Lothmann sagt eben das
eigentlich Räume in der Literatur
widerspiegeln wie wir auch denken also
unsere eigenen Denksysteme widerspiegeln
auch unsere eigenen Räume widerspiegeln
und die grundsätzliche Theorie besagt
dass wir eben eine erzählte Welt oder
ein erzählten Raum haben und jegliche
Art von Raum wird durch eben eine Grenze
in zwei Teilräume unterteilt also
Teilraum 1 und Teilraum 2 das
Wesentliche an diesen beiden Räumen ist
dass die sich strukturell voneinander
unterscheiden also die Grenzen haben
sozusagen dann auch eine eine
bedeutungstragende Funktion also sowas
zum Beispiel wie zwischen Leben und Tod
zwischen drinnen und draußen zwischen
oben und unten zwischen weiß ich nicht
zu Hause und dem dunklen Finsterwald wo
ganz viele Monster sind oder so also es
gibt sagen immer diese qualitativ
unterschiedlichen Räume
und das entscheiden dann diesen Grenzen
ist dass sie unüberwindlich sind oder
unüberwindlich scheinen ja dass da
eigentlich jeder der in dem Teilraum 1
ist nicht in Teilraum 2 geht und
umgekehrt ja es sagen die Leute die in
dem Dorf sind würden nicht in den bösen
Finsterwald gehen weil da ist es ja
gefährlich da laufen Monster rum oder
die Hexe oder der Zauberer oder wie auch
immer gefährlich geht man nicht hin
bleibt man lieber zu Hause das ist die
Idee dieser Grenzziehung
das Schöne an dieser Grenze ist dass die
Grenze nicht nur physisch sein muss das
kann auch eine andere Art von Grenze
sein also sowas zum Beispiel wie soziale
Grenzen haben wir sowas wie bei Romeo
und Julia wir haben zwei Häuser Julia
und Romeo dürfen sich aber überhaupt
nicht kennen eigentlich die dürfen sich
auf keinen Fall lieben weil die Häuser
sind ja
verfeindet es gibt die Grenze zwischen
den beiden Häusern und diese Grenze ist
eigentlich unüberstreitbar ja also
soziale Grenzen religiöse Grenzen
auf politischer Ebene zum Beispiel oder
auch sowas wie zwischen Leben und Tod
ist immer ganz interessant wenn man so
grenzfiguren hat wie den Vampir der auf
einmal beides ist ja also der lebt und
ist tot aber irgendwie wie geht das denn
eigentlich auch ein schönes Sache
worüber sie man sich gerne Gedanken
machen kann wie das noch damit
zusammenhängt aber das Entscheidende ist
eben es gibt immer einen
oder eine oder mehrere kann auch eine
Gruppe sein oder eben auch Leute die
sich wieder als Frau oder als Mann
definieren geht ja auch wie gesagt
irgendjemandem der in der Lage ist diese
Grenze auf einmal doch zu überschreiten
ja das sind normalerweise die Heldinnen
ja heldenheldinnen Heldengruppe die in
der Lage sind diese Grenze zu
überschreiten im Vergleich zu anderen an
allen anderen nicht beweglichen Figuren
die eben diese Grenze als gegeben
akzeptieren und dessen nennen nennt lot
man eben auch ein Ereignis also sobald
wir eine Grenze da überschreiten in dem
Text dann entsteht ein Ereignis und
eigentlich dann wird ein Text er
spannend dann entsteht ein Text
eigentlich erst weil wir diese Grenze
überschreiten
lot man nennt es eben Sujet also dass
man eben diese Grenzüberschreitung hat
das Ereignis und ich habe mir jetzt
gedacht wie ist es mit lernereignissen
ja also lernereignisse müssten ja dann
auch irgendetwas sein wie wir grenzen
überschreiten können also wo
überschreiten wir eigentlich Grenzen in
der Lehre oder die Heldinnen Grenzen in
der Lehre damit so ein Ereignis
überhaupt zustande kommt und dann wird
irgend Spannung aufkommt damit ein
wirklich gutes Lernen Ereignis entstehen
kann und wie gesagt als
Gedankenexperiment werfe ich vielleicht
mehr Fragen auf als Antworten zu geben
aber ich möchte es einfach mal diese
verschiedenen Ideen dazu durchspielen
die mir da gekommen sind ich habe jetzt
mal so sieben Felder oder Bereiche
Aspekte mir mal rausgepickt sieben
einfach deswegen weil 7 so eine magische
Zahl ist die auch ganz oft in
heldenreisen vorkommt deswegen sind
jetzt sieben nicht zufällig ich habe es
tatsächlich inkonstruiert also insofern
könnten auch mehr oder weniger sein aber
ich mache jetzt mal sieben
und die erste Frage ist eben was für
Grenzen haben wir eigentlich in der
online-lehre man kann genauso sagen
welche Grenzen haben wir in der Lehre
oder welche Grenzen habt ihr eigentlich
in euren einzelnen Fachbereichen die
überschritten werden müssen also das
sind einmal inhaltliche Grenzen welche
Grenzen gibt es da die unüberwindlich
erscheinen ey man ihr kennt es
vielleicht von euren Studis auch was
sind so die Knackpunkte wo die echt
sagen boah nee das mache ich nicht bei
uns ist immer lyrikanalyse ja gut Leute
sagen boah nee habe ich so schlechte
Erfahrungen damit gemacht will ich gar
nichts mit zu tun haben und ich lerne
das auch nicht mehr ja also
Schreibzentrum immer dieses Schreiben
ist für Leute die das können lernen tue
ich das nicht ich konnte noch nie
schreiben das sind so ganz klassische
aussagen wenn man so eine Grenze als
unüberwindlich sieht
und in der online-lehre kann man sich ja
auch überlegen was sind da so Grenzen
die uns eigentlich begegnen das eine
sind ja so diese visuellen Grenzen ja
dass wir nicht sehen was passiert
eigentlich außerhalb dieser Kamera ja
also wer läuft da noch so rum ich habe
sowas öfters dann das irgendwie Katzen
oder Hunde im Hintergrund sind sobald
irgendeine durchs Bild läuft läuft hat
man keine Aufmerksamkeit mehr da muss
man irgendwie damit arbeiten solche
Dinge zum Beispiel oder was sieht man
nicht was die Studierenden während einer
Präsentation oder was noch tun in
irgendwelchen E-Mail Programmen rum ich
meine kann ja jetzt beim Vortrag genauso
sein sind die Leute überhaupt da kann
ich sie sehen weil sie die Kamera
ausgeschaltet haben oder nicht wie gehe
ich mit dieser Situation eigentlich um
damit es trotzdem noch produktiv bleibt
genauso die auditiven Grenzen also die
Frage macht es überhaupt Sinn dass alle
das Mikrofon aushalten klar positiv ist
dass man im Endeffekt die
Hintergrundgeräusche nicht hat aber auf
der anderen Seite geht ganz viel an
Räumlichkeit verloren weil man natürlich
auch diese Sachen wie ja so so
zustimmendes lachen oder sowas hat man
dann nicht mehr ja die Frage kann man in
kleinen Gruppen vielleicht sagen wir
lassen einfach das Mikro an damit man da
diesen Kontakt weiterhin
aufrechterhalten kann andere Grenzen
wenn man auf die Sinne sich konzentriert
wer auch sowas wie haptische Grenzen ja
wir können nicht gemeinsam an einem
Whiteboard Arbeiten Überlegung
vielleicht man könnte in der Wohnung
trotzdem mit irgendwelchen Objekten
Arbeiten weiß ich nicht
literaturstudenten holt doch mal euer
Lieblingsbuch holt euch das mal aus dem
Schrank raus oder sowas sogar in die
Richtung olfaktorisch oder gustatorisch
kann ich mit irgendwelchen Gewürzen
arbeiten und die Leute irgendwas
beschreiben lassen vergleichen lassen
das Ding als Metapher nutzen um
irgendwas zu erklären ja also es ist ja
auch vielleicht eine Idee dass man mit
den Dingen arbeitet die jeder so ein
üblicherweise zu Hause hat und dadurch
versucht irgendwas zu erklären womit man
eine sinnliche Erfahrung entstehen
lassen kann also multisensorisch nicht
nur gucken sondern vielleicht auch
andere Sinne anzusprechen um das Ganze
ein bisschen interessanter werden zu
lassen in der online-lehre
da gibt es ja auch diese schönen
interessanten
lernmotivatoren nach spitzer die finde
ich eigentlich echt super wer die noch
nicht kennt ich habe da mal einen Link
reingesetzt in den Chat das sind
verschiedene lernmotivatoren also wie
lernt man gut und dass man damals checkt
mache ich meine online-lehre oder Lehre
so dass diese Motivatoren auch alle
bedient werden also sowas wie Spaß
soziale Einbindung Herausforderungen und
sowas also dass man das nutzt um eben
auch das eigene lernereignis wirklich
auf verschiedenen Ebenen motivatorisch
sinnvoll zu gestalten
als nächstes unsere Heldinnen ja wir
sind eigentlich unsere Heldinnen bin ich
selber die Heldin meines Kurses oder ist
eigentlich die Idee dass die
Studierenden unsere Helden und Heldinnen
sind die sich eben da auf in ein
Abenteuer reinbegeben und eben
vielleicht bei dieser Grenze wissen
nicht wissen vom nicht wissen zum Wissen
kommen und diese Grenze überschreiten
müssen und das ist eben so eine
Haltungsfrage wie sehe ich einen
eigentlich meine Studierenden sehe ich
die als Kompetenz als Heldinnen die das
schaffen können und was kann ich tun
damit die Leute auch befähigt werden die
Grenzen zu überschreiten die vor ihnen
stehen also bin ich da vielleicht eine
helferfigur die ihnen über die Grenze
hilft und gebe eben nur so nebenbei
irgendwas mit Ran gute Hinweise oder so
oder bin ich selber eine Heldin die
mitreißt oder bin ich mehr so in
Richtung personale Erzählsituation
unterwegs und sagt ihr macht das alles
selber ich nehme das einfach nur auf und
ihr müsst euch das wirklich total
selbstgesteuert erarbeiten ja was kann
ich da tun wo will ich wo will ich mich
selber sehen in dieser auf dieser Reise
von denen wie stark bringe ich mich ein
wie stark gehe ich vielleicht weiter
zurück und habe dadurch vielleicht auch
einen anderen Bezug und eben die Frage
wo mit müssen die Heldinnen überhaupt
ausgestattet werden damit sie diese also
diese diese diese diese Grenze
überschreiten können wenn man jetzt in
Richtung online-lehre schaut da kann man
natürlich sehr textbasiert arbeiten also
viele Arbeiten jetzt zum Beispiel mit
Nudeln dass da ganz viele Texte immer
hochgeladen werden die die Leute lesen
müssen die Frage ist kann man nicht viel
mehr auch Audio selber einbinden Podcast
selber machen also weil ihr immer dieses
persönliche ja auch also da wieder zu
Sandra dieser Persönlichkeit die man ja
ist dass man die nicht nur vielleicht
wenn man wenn es so ist dass wir
Präsenzlehre haben und online-lehre
können wir die online-lehre nicht auch
persönlich gestalten dass wir eben
selber mit unseren Video mit auftreten
oder selber mit den Leuten sprechen
indem wir ein Podcast aufnehmen oder
sonst irgendwelche anderen Links setzen
die die nutzen können im Netz wo eben
auch ein bisschen mehr Multi visuelle
oder Multi
also multifaktorielle Inhalte da geboten
werden und das letztes auch so ein
bisschen dieser diese Stärkung des
Selbstvertrauens ja also da dass die
Studierenden auch sich selber als
Heldinnen überhaupt wahrnehmen dass sie
das schaffen können weil ich glaube ein
sehr großer Aspekt bei unserer Lehre an
der Universität ist dass viele sich auch
einfach überfordert fühlen die das
Gefühl haben dass es so viel das ist zu
groß das schaffe ich nicht wenn
unglaublich viel zu tun ist wenn es
unglaublich komplexe Inhalte sind dass
man den Leuten da auch auf so einer
Ebene wie kann ich den Leuten
Selbstvertrauen geben dass sie das auch
wirklich schaffen werden viele sich
selber als Heldinnen sehen passiert es
vielleicht eher als wenn Sie dieses
Gefühl nicht haben vielleicht auch ein
Gruppengefühl dass sie sich gemeinsam in
der Gruppe auf so eine queste begeben
und das wäre sozusagen das nächste was
ist die Queste oder die Belohnung die
die Studierenden am Ende bekommen ja
also welche Reise treten sie an
außer ja ich muss die Prüfung bestehen
vielleicht gibt es auch noch was anderes
was ich mir überlegen kann was so eine
Belohnung sein kann ja am Ende so die
wir die Queste die wir zusammen
erreichen und am Ende gibt es irgendwas
keine Ahnung
gehen wir zusammen ins Kino oder so ich
weiß es nicht oder es gibt vielleicht
sogar einfach irgendwelche Zusatzinfos
die spannend klingen die man den Leuten
dann halt einfach gibt wenn Sie die
Queste bestehen ja bis zum Ende hin ja
vielleicht auch eine Überlegung aber
welche Auftrag ist es denen die Leute zu
erledigen haben welches Ziel wollen wir
tatsächlich erreichen mit unserem
Onlinekurs und da eben noch mal diese
Idee der Heldenreise als Gruppe ja also
ich meine jeder der Rollenspiele kennt
da gibt es auch immer eine Gruppe die
sich zusammenfindet die dann irgendein
Abenteuer erleben muss und diese Gruppe
besteht immer aus unterschiedlichen
Leuten also den Zwerg der Zauberer die
Magierin die Hexe der Elf die Elfen das
ist immer so eine Heldengruppe wie bei
Herr der Ringe die unterschiedliche
Fähigkeiten haben sich zusammenfinden
und dadurch dass sie unterschiedlich
sind in ihren Fähigkeiten können Sie
diese queste dann überhaupt bestehen und
dass man vielleicht nicht zufällig
irgendwelche Gruppen arbeiten macht
vielleicht auch nicht nur in einer
Sitzung sondern dass sie über das
Semester hinweg vielleicht sich zusammen
befinden als Gruppe unterschiedlich
besetzt und dann eben die Aufgaben die
zu tun sind gemeinsam lösen können und
dadurch profitieren dass sie eben
unterschiedlich sind vielleicht kann man
da auch in die Richtung bisschen
zusammen denken
dazu muss tatsächlich einerseits die
Belohnung aber auch der Zielraum wo es
hingehen soll in gewisser Weise
attraktiv sein wie attraktiv ist es
eigentlich dass ich dahin gehe und
überhaupt diese Grenze überschreite ja
also mit der Lyrik ist es ja immer so
eine Sache ja finden die Leute das
überhaupt toll ja kann ich das irgendwie
so hinbringen dass sie irgendwann
genauso cool finden wie ich oder
vielleicht auch ich Unterschied auch
sowas wie wissenschaftliches Arbeiten
und Schreiben haben sie ja schon
mitbekommen
das ist auch nicht immer so dass die
Leute sagen ja okay ich habe einen Kurs
zum wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten ja also
das sind auch so Dinge wo man sich ganz
viel motivatorisch einfach überlegen
sollte wie kriege ich die Leute dann
trotzdem dazu dass irgendwie spannend zu
finden oder wenigstens sinnvoll wäre ja
auch schon mal was
und im
auch dieser Zielraum also mit dem die
Frage mit dem digitalen jetzt noch mal
also dieser digitale Raum kann ich den
auch in gewisser Weise attraktiv machen
also sowas wie ein digitales Lagerfeuer
erzeugen ja dass ich die Leute
vielleicht auch mal privat dort
irgendwie treffen und austauschen können
dass sie auch nicht nur das als
irgendeine Plattform sehen sondern
vielleicht auch ein als ein
Begegnungsraum den wir natürlich
gestalten müssen also bisschen Spaß
reinzubringen wie sowas über so Crysis
dann eben auch die dann passen vorn ich
meine das muss man dann ein bisschen
ausgestalten
es gibt da auch zum Beispiel
diese Idee der Web Quests kennt
vielleicht auch der ein oder andere wo
man die Leute dann auch tatsächlich
erstmal auf eine Web Quest schickt und
die dann eben selber
da eben auch sie mit Ressourcen
ausstattet die sich dann selber lösen
müssen ich kann dann auch noch mal einen
Link dazu reingeben
aber auch so ein bisschen mehr in die
Richtung was kann ich was was kann ich
visuell machen kann ich es bunter machen
visueller klarer bildlicher kann ich
Videos erstellen also dass wenn alles
Dinge die ich mir dazu überlegen kann
dann die Frage
[Musik]
da hat ja super da sehen wir den wie das
funktioniert wenn man den Hintergrund
mit drin hat das ist wie als hätte ich
es jetzt gefragt ja das kann es mal
einer machen also dass man da ein
bisschen mehr wahrnimmt von dem was im
Hintergrund gerade passiert ja also das
ist kann auch eine positive Sache sein
man muss nicht als Störung empfinden
zum Thema helferfiguren und magische
Objekte also das ist ja auch sowas oft
gibt es ja so diese helferfiguren die
magischen Objekte die uns weiterhelfen
darin wie kommen wir überhaupt weiter in
unserer Arbeit also können wir
vielleicht unsere ganze Lehre auch ein
bisschen mehr systematisch aufeinander
aufbauen von leicht nach schwer mit
einzelnen Herausforderungen wo wir den
Leuten immer nach und nach bestimmte
Informationen geben die Ihnen helfen
bestimmte challenges sozusagen dann auch
dann selber
zu bearbeiten und selber die Ressourcen
dann zu haben gewisse Aufgaben zu lösen
und nicht gleich immer so die
erschlagende Menge an Texten sagen nehmt
mal und dann macht ihr das irgendwie
schon sondern ein bisschen mehr in
kleineren einfacheren Stufen denken was
kann ich den Leuten nach und nach geben
damit sie tatsächlich irgendwo eine
Aufgabe lösen können auch die Frage
inwiefern bin ich diese Hel Figur kann
ich vielleicht eher so kryptische
Hinweise geben oder mache ich es recht
klar also kann ich mich ja auch
entscheiden wie gebe ich die
und dazu eben auch Gegnerinnen einbauen
ja also diese bösen Drachen ja oder den
bösen enddrachen wenigstens die
Prüfungen ja aber dass man vielleicht da
auch versucht wie wie kann ich vorher
Gegner schalten die kleine Gegner sind
die man erstmal besiegen muss dass dann
die Prüfung am Ende nicht so wie dieser
riesen fette fiese Drache ausschaut
sondern dass die vielleicht fangt mal
erst mal mit der kleinen
gefährlichen Micky Maus an oder so die
man die man bekämpfen muss und
irgendwann kommt man zu dem fiesen der
Drachen dann schon hin aber dass man
über diese stufenprinzip dann bisschen
reinkommt aber auch das ganze als
Herausforderung zu machen also eine
Herausforderung zu liefern indem eben
die Leute selbst lernerisch eben auch
Aufgaben lösen die vielleicht wirklich
nicht super easy sind aber die man
tatsächlich eben so ein Projektgruppen
vielleicht auch die Leute selbstständig
lösen lassen kann dass die dann auch so
ein positives Lernerlebnis haben
und das ganze hängt eigentlich so ein
bisschen damit zusammen dass man so sich
überlegt was ist die eigene Story in
meinem Kurs das ist eben nicht nur so
ist ja wir haben jetzt hier einen Kurs
am Ende gibt es die Prüfung und ihr
macht es halt und wir machen das und so
sondern dass man sich überlegt was Story
in this ja also kann ich vielleicht
irgendwie mir überlegen es gibt
verschiedenes wie so
ein bestimmtes Genre ich möchte das
ganze vielleicht mehr wie eine
Detektivgeschichte aufbauen ich möchte
vielleicht ein Abenteuer draus machen
für meine Studis ich möchte dass sie ein
Rätsel lösen am Ende ich will dass die
keine Ahnung so ein Lara Croft Gefühl
bekommen oder sie gehen in die Anderwelt
oder wie auch immer dass man das ganze
so ein bisschen in eine Geschichte
reinpackt weil ich glaube dass viele
Leute Geschichten mögen weiß nicht wie
es euch geht ob ihr gerne Geschichten
liest oder hört aber dass das was ist
was eine Emotion anspricht also die Idee
bei der Story ist immer die Emotionen
kann ich eine Emotion auslösen bei
meinen studieren dass sie sagen da habe
ich jetzt Bock drauf da habe ich jetzt
richtig Bock drauf diesen Kurs machen
ich bin zum Beispiel bei Marie von
Wurzelwerk ich mache so ein Onlinekurs
zum Gärtnern ich bin stolze Besitzerin
eines Schrebergartens also eine
töchterin und ich finde es total super
das ist auch so eine queste für mich
eigentlich und das ist so ein bisschen
die Idee ja kriege ich irgendwie so eine
Story hin die vielleicht auch so
bestimmte Dramaturgie verfolgt dass ich
das eben in meinem eigenen Kurs
kreieren kann